looks like the North Korean summit is
off did you hear about this yeah this
morning president Trump canceled his
summit with Kim jong-un saying it's
because of Kim's open hostility yeah
Trump said I will not tolerate hostility
from a fat face little rocket man that
guy's got a temper uh president Trump in
forum do you know this he informed Kim
jong-un that he was canceling their
summit by sending Kim a personal letter
yeah the disturbing part is the Trump
signed the letter yours in crazy their
pals yeah yeah a new report just came
out says the US military is running out
of bombs can you believe that running
out of bombs it's bad as of now the
Pentagon is down to 100 bunker busters
and six copies of the emoji movie
now folks I thank you
very much thank you I'm here all week
thank you very much be good to your
waitress Froot Loops any Froot Loops
fans here I love a show finally that
unites us huh our love of sugared
cereals Froot Loops cereal has added a
new flavor
wild berry yeah people who tried the new
flavors say it tastes like wild berries
plus sugar - wild berries but I
mentioned this dr. zarnow warning about
the spread of something they are calling
super gonorrhea super gonorrhea yeah
it's hard to believe that now the cool
thing to say to a woman in a bar is it's
okay I only have regular gonorrhea
I'm miming leaning against the bar
that's way too high
you